we just got huge airpods pro 2 leaks
some of these make a whole lot of sense
while others i was not expecting but
thinking about it i guess apple would do
something like this and a couple i just
kind of disagree with so let's go ahead
and jump into everything we know and
everything that just makes sense such as
the release date a new design we're
gonna talk about sound quality battery
life new sensors and chips and i just
gotta say that i am very excited these
news come from ming chi quo he has an
excellent track record he's been
providing us with solid leaks for many
years now such as updates to iphones a
lot of things on macbooks for example
the sd card reader hdmi redesigned mac
safe coming back a lot of things we
didn't really kind of expect or really
believe you talked about new iphones new
ipad pros with many led and a couple
things that he got wrong well a lot of
them were just dates for example the new
airpods 3 coming out
with the launch of the iphone instead of
a month later things like that so he has
a great track record and the first thing
that he mentioned is the release date
now this makes a whole lot of sense he's
saying that they're going to launch in
the fourth quarter of 2022
so yes pretty much a year from now maybe
10 months or so
now i wish it was coming out sooner but
this makes a whole lot of sense because
apple launched their air pods in 2016.
that was a long time ago and then a few
years later they did a minor update with
a new chip a little bit better battery
life and the wireless charging case but
it was a very minor update and the
airpods pro well those came out two
years ago and with the launch of the
airpods pro 2 that will be three years
so that is a life cycle that perfectly
aligns
just because apple doesn't have much
competition that offers everything that
these do including the ios integration
now there are a couple things that we
can absolutely expect with the airpods
pro 2 the first being better sound
quality i just reviewed the airpods 3
after a month of using them and i
mentioned that i stopped using the
airpods pro
in every situation other than if i need
active noise cancellation for example if
i'm doing chores like vacuuming or
mowing the lawn or things like that just
because the sound quality in the airpods
3 are better they have new drivers the
sound profile is more natural and a lot
of audiophiles agree with this even
though they're not sealed into their
your ear which does limit for example of
ultra low base there's a couple things
like you know sound leaking in so apple
is definitely gonna be upgrading the
drivers and i think if the airpods 3
sound this good the airpods pro 2 are
gonna sound amazing and if you look at
the competition from the new sony's we
have a lot of other brands that are
coming out with great sound quality they
really need this update they've needed
it for at least a year now heck even
their own beats studio buds which come
in at 150 bucks sound better than the
earpods pro and they have better active
noise cancellation as well which we'll
talk about in just a sec so apple has to
step this up now the other thing is
battery life the airpods 3 had a big
jump in battery life especially real
world battery life better than what
they're rated and i think the airpods
pro are also going to get better so with
a better battery life and more
efficiency these are going to last a lot
longer now quo also said that there's
going to be a new chip that improves
connectivity with devices now it's kind
of obvious that they're not going to use
the same chip that's going to be three
four years old at this point they're
gonna have one that's more efficient but
the connectivity is very interesting so
are these finally gonna get the latest
and great greatest bluetooth and are
they going to allow you to play lossless
audio apple has been making a huge push
with apple music and that got a lot of
people including me to sign back up for
apple music for their higher quality
streaming but of course you can't stream
that without extra conditional
compression to these airpods or any
bluetooth device so if apple figured out
a way to do wi-fi audio or airplay audio
with you know buffering which when we
did the math like a second of buffering
can transfer a song
that would be amazing and i would sell a
lot of airpods now of course we have to
have a new chip for better active noise
cancellation and better adaptive eq all
of that stuff is limited by that chip so
active noise cancellation will get a lot
better and people have complained that
with firmware updates active noise
cancellation has gotten quite a bit
worse than when they first came out so
i'm definitely looking forward to that
as well for airpod pros to be better
than beats studio buzz in terms of
active noise cancellation quo also said
that there are going to be new sensors
that have fitness tracking capabilities
built in now this is one that i'm very
hesitant about and i
don't want to give it a whole lot of
truth for one reason and that reason is
that apple knows how to make money for
example when they released the ipad pro
with the m1 chip and thunderbolt 4 and
had just amazing specs that mini led
display
they really limited it with software so
that you still have to buy a macbook
they don't want to replace one device
with another they want you to buy both
so i don't think that apple would put in
a bunch of fitness trackers and allow
you to not have to buy an apple watch i
feel like if they added new sensors it
might make it more accurate it might
give you some extra capabilities but
they will not just say hey you don't
need to get this for heart rate sensing
for fitness tracking uh calories any of
that stuff just buy these airpod pros i
could be wrong let me know your opinion
but apple is very good at maximizing it
and having you buy their full ecosystem
to have a you know very great experience
now one sensor that is going to be
updated is the optical sensor we know
what the air pods three though they got
rid of that and they put in a skin
detect sensor so they only turn on when
they are in your ear canal or in your
ear and they sense the skin so if you
put them in your pockets they will not
turn on like the airpods
pro will right now or in another place
where it's touching something and it's
dark so that's gonna be a nice feature
that's obviously a sensor that will get
updated and now let's talk about
probably the biggest thing and that is
the design
quote is saying that they are going to
get rid of these iconic stems and
they're going to go for a clean look
just like the beats fit pro
now this is something i was not
expecting uh this is just so iconic from
the original ones that stuck out like
you know toothbrush heads to these ones
that are much cleaner and i'm kind of
hesitant about this because of just how
great the controls are they're tactile
you're not tapping on the butt or doing
anything like that they work so well but
if you think about it it does make a
whole lot of sense because apple wants
to change things because people will buy
it if there's a change for example new
iphone redesign crazy sales new macbook
redesigns these 14 and 16 inch really
good sales people want to buy something
that looks and feels different and then
of course there's the show off factor
which sounds weird to say but people
like it so that when other people see
that you have you know something it's
the new design it's the latest and
greatest people bought the airpods that
looked weird because you could tell that
you have the latest and greatest when
apple made the airpods pro they changed
the design so people can tell that you
have the latest and now that the airpods
3 took that same iconic design and they
basically look the same as the airpods
pro when they are in your ear if they
kept the same design well it just
there's no difference there you don't
feel like there's a difference whereas
if they change it to a more streamlined
look it looks different of course it's
not going to have the meat's logo will
probably look a little bit different
but if people see that in your ear it's
going to look different they're it's
going to feel different
and people like that that is just the
truth so you guys let me know what your
thoughts are on this new design being
like the beats fit pro is that something
you're happy with do you like the more
streamlined look without anything
sticking out or do you prefer the stems
that are currently on the airpods and of
course colors people been talking about
that for a long time
um people wanted even the original
earpods hey give us black give us some
other colors i want to say that i do not
think this is going to happen if it was
going to happen apple would have done
that with the airpods 3 that's the more
of their cheaper consumer line they do
that with the cheaper iphones if you buy
the cheaper imacs you get a bunch of
colors so would not it makes sense for
apple to not give you colors for these
and then all sudden bring colors to
the airpods pro i mean maybe there's a
small chance that they could do a black
version that would be cool but then
again it would look more like beats if
they have that in-ear design whereas the
white is just so iconic for apple so
there you guys go we have the release
date we have the new design we have some
new sensors that could probably work
with my opinion with the apple watch um
and of course we're gonna get updates
like sound quality active noise
cancellation and other things so it
should be a really nice update and i'm
estimating it'll still be 250 bucks i
don't think they'll make it more
expensive with the airpods 3 they
actually made it slightly cheaper
compared to the airpods 2 with a
wireless charging case but you guys let
me know your thoughts as well i'm super
excited i cannot wait and it sucks that
we're waiting close to a year for these
this has been max click that circle
above to subscribe to help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers check out
one of those videos there specifically
the airpods 3 review after one month and
i will see you guys in the next video
[Music]